okay so previously I want to get our
head back into space I suppose the fact
that you've spent a couple of days
thinking about other things just like I
have is a perfect reason to have a look
at this so leave space you're heading
because it's a bit of spoiler
what have we looked at think right to
the beginning of a current extension to
sort of topic what if we do look at in
polynomials can someone give me some
like dot points
okay so I'm gonna put that yeah roots
and coefficients maybe you if we've
looked at their results okay what else
if we looked at multiplicity of Reds
just rewinding a little bit before we
looked at those we also look at the fact
that because as extension to students we
have a broader field of understanding
for what numbers are we've looked at
different kinds of oddities right what
clients yeah very good sir I would say
on complex coefficients and complex
roots which go with that so that's when
we had a look in more detail at the
proof the complex conjugate rift here
right okay that's a pretty good start
what's the most recent thing that we
have looked at do you remember something
in common with trigonometry before
starts with an eye we looked at
polynomial all I can think of is
polynomial Yates polynomial identities
do you remember that we looked at those
recently and just like when we learn
trigonometric identities polynomial
identities where this tool that we use
like just rephrasing the question that's
all you're doing
right you're like dressing up the same
question in different clothes very
powerful tool for being able to help us
Sophie's right now we are going to pick
right up from this guy here polynomial
identities and rather than showing how
you can
to make solving an equation easier do
you remember how we turn the court
aquatic into a quadratic using a
particular polynomial in today rather
than focus on equations we're going to
focus on something else that is made
easier by polynomial identities one I
don't want to tell you what it is yet
cause it's a spoiler so to get there I
want you to consider this little
expression okay consider and here is the
experiment that I've got I think that's
a lot okay it's a sir what does this
happen to do with anything
well it'll emerge as we start going
through it you know look at this this is
a pair of fractions and if you saw this
unlike a year eight or year nine test
okay probably the first thing you would
do is say that's two fractions I am
going to put them together into one that
will be simplified right so just humor
me for a minute
and let's go ahead and do that so if I
combine these two I need to comment
denominator what am i comment
denominator B it's just the product of
those song and have this on and then
order to put them together I'm gonna
have to modify this numerator so they
fit or my needle in it okay so it looks
like I'm gonna have two of these and for
all these you happy with that okay so
let me just tidy this up a little bit up
on my numerator it seems like I'm going
to have 2x plus 4x which is 6x
two x plus four X is 6x what constant
term have I got plus two because I've
got six minus four X plus two and just
for the sake of it because it will help
me later on I'm gonna go ahead and
expand this I'm not gonna do it as the
pair of binomials come on it's gonna be
a quadratic so I think it adds to all
your courses is Manik it starts with X
square the coefficient of x will be plus
two because it's the sum and then the
constant term will be negative three
because it's the product okay happy
times no yes I think that's as good as
it gets
I appreciate as good as it gets unless
okay now what have we done here just
having a look at the first line and the
last line
okay keyboarding what I've done is if
you think about this in Reverse if you
play it in reverse order right
what you've done is you've got one
fraction and you can express it as two
parts right two other fractions so
because these two I need new color
because these two fractions up here are
each a part of this one fraction right
we give them a name based on the fact
that they're both fractions and they
form a pot they call parts of the
original we call these guys partial
fractions
partial fractions right so that's kind
of okay will be for you you've made a
new name you've done you can you call
this something all right
why is that useful get to that in a
second okay what I want to ask though is
like this was easy to do as we just said
like all these events into thing to do
to combine fractions together
that's simplifying their problem what if
I wanted to go in the reverse order
what if I wanted to start with this and
say well what original pair of fractions
did you come from what if I went in the
opposite direction instead of combining
what if I were decomposing right well
not if I were physically present but
what if I were decomposing that as I
call it decompose this into its partial
fractions okay how do I go about doing
it well what I'm going to hypothesize is
that this thing here right because I can
see this denominator can be factorized
right without knowing too much about
that I can already see that that is
because so what I'm going to applaud the
size is I'm going to introduce a good
morning and identity right equal and
always equal to some pair of fractions
that has the two factors as the two
denominated it's got to come from
something like that right so there's an
X minus 1 and X plus 3 okay but if I'm
starting from here like this is what I
know that I don't if I didn't know this
from the beginning
right at least for me I don't
immediately I go what are these numbers
like how do I come up with them I don't
know what they are so of course the
superpower algebra is to say oh it
doesn't matter if I don't know let's
just give them some names and see what
we can conclude and me I'm just gonna
say yeah there's something that's
constant I don't know if they are yet
I'm gonna try to find out okay so if I'm
introducing identity how am I gonna go
about actually working out what the
numbers are cuz we've done this all the
time we're like express this in this
form and find out what alien beings
hang on whatever what should I do yeah
yeah yeah there you go
okay so first I need to put these
together don't I now that one of the
reasons why this can be helpful is just
like in st. Paul desert a Mahal or treat
right I hope you get that I'm trying to
draw the parallels all the time okay in
auxilary angle what we want is both
sides are sine X plus alpha sine X plus
kha'zix or whatever we want them to look
as similar as possible because what's
the point of doing that what happens in
this one then I can compare coefficients
right or real and imaginary parts or
whatever I'm doing right so if I get the
denominators the same that'll be a
really helpful step let's do it
this is equal and always equal to now
this is gonna look just like this right
because I'm doing the same thing I just
don't know what the numerators are so
this is gonna look just like this
and now because I have gotten the common
denominator all I really need to worry
about is the numerators right as well I
said all I need to really do is shift
this a little bit so I can compare the
coefficients right so when you have a
look at this this is kind of factored
out in a way that's inconvenient to me I
want to know what the X terms are and I
want to know what their constant terms
are yes so let's have a look how many x
terms do I have but it must be of the
X's right so I'm gonna factor that out a
plus B turn to the exit and then when
you have a look at the constants I've
got three a there - B yeah
so even though it's a little bit
redundant I'm going to put them in
brackets anyway to indicate there one
thing that's the constant term there
there are no other constant terms in the
numerator so that was the entire thing
and of course I've got my so now that
everything I need to put them into the
right form I'm gonna now save by
comparison of coefficients
and I've got two coefficients I need to
compare the X term or the X to the 1
term and the constant term which is the
X to the naught term okay so you can see
that guy there is equal always equal to
that that guy there equal always equal
to that so let's go ahead for that a
plus B equals what we say six
done so you see just like we've seen so
many situations you compare coefficients
and that gives you a pair of
simultaneous equations just like I did
with dogs in angle and we need to just
go ahead and solve what's the obvious
thing to do in this particular pair I'm
gonna add which won't eliminate out the
B's from this so when I go one plus two
that's just going to give me four a
equals eight
hence a equals 2 which we because we
crafted this question we already knew
that but if you just took that away
there's nothing that obviously says to
you oh of course it's a 2 right we had
to sort of logic that out and then of
course if you take that I'm going to
substitute that back into 1 and that
tells me right off the bat that B is
equal to 4 as required as we already so
this is this process of taking one
fraction and decomposing it into partial
fractions okay before I go on I don't
want to ask any questions
okay yes we will get to all different
kinds of cases of doing this this is a
pretty well it's about as simple as the
cases that could have come up with just
so we get to see their principal on how
it works
okay so let's conclude down the bottom
here okay what I have just established
is that 6x plus 2 on this denominator is
equal to that pair of fractions and I've
done it without any prior knowledge or
that without drawing any prior knowledge
of what the actual partial fractions
were I did it through scratch as it were
like I knew nothing about what these
would be and I worked it out okay so
what's the point of doing that what is
it that just like before polynomial
identities they were useful for making
equations easier to solve what's the use
of this yeah okay so if I do this
suddenly this somewhat arbitrary and
esoteric ooh let's make one fraction
into two this kind of random sort of
problem now unveils its real power right
because when you have a look at that
first the left hand side right you look
at this disaster okay what on earth do
you do with that you might think oh it's
okay I'll take it a factor of two you
get three X plus one which is completely
useless to you all we know to do with
rational integrands like this is to
search for an F dash on F and there's no
twisting and turning you can do to turn
this into an F - it's not gonna happen
okay so if I can unravel like that the
reason it's a problem is because this
guy this guy don't climb
like in the same way that I want to if I
can decompose into a pair of fractions
this is trivial like super sugary or in
fact what's going to happen if I didn't
have a two day if I just have a 1 what
will that integrate into log of X minus
1 exit box are two of them so then I
just say to law X minus one in exactly
the same way you have a look at this
it would integrate into log of X plus
three but four of them so you're gonna
go like so and because it's indefinite
of course I'm going to say that's ok so
you can see I have turned an otherwise
in so legal problem like this is the
kind of problem you look at me like
don't know how to do this right with
very simple skills right and the
critical idea of the polynomial identity
which seems fairly innocuous really but
actually it's um it just reduces this
question down to size okay that's
extension to students yes yes because
it's because if you were doing something
with this style this guy and you think
about the domain of these functions okay
the domain of these functions includes
all kinds of reader negative values so
therefore I want to reflect that in cost
and we established why in fact you're
actually doing two integrations at once
then you've done this because you're
ending up at the positive log n native
at the same time because of the domain